die afg hat in sachsen und in
brandenburg sehr starke ergebnisse
erzielt aber ihr großes wahlziel
stärkste partei zu werden haben sie
nicht erreicht wie beurteilen sie die
wahlergebnisse also was zählt sind nicht
die prognosen sondern was zählt das
ergebnis und wir haben ein fulminantes
hervorragendes ergebnis eingefahren dass
wir feiern wir haben einen historischen
höchststand erreicht in brandenburg und
in sachsen und vor allen dingen für
sachsen gilt nun dass 60 prozent der
wähler konservativ gewählt haben und da
wird sich die cdu fragen müssen ob sie
diese blockadehaltung doch beibehalten
möchte die cdu hat hier in sachsen und
natürlich auch in allen anderen
bundesländer klare position keine
zusammenarbeit mit der afd
was wollen sie denn für ihre partei für
ihre wähler erreicht wenn kein anderer
mit ihnen zusammenarbeitet ja also die
frage zurückgestellt ist ja ich glaube
nicht mehr dass die parteien
strategisch gesehen an uns vorbeikommen
man wird mit uns reden müssen als
konservative kraft und genau das ist ja
den regierungsparteien spd und cdu auf
die füße gefahren es ist der umgang mit
uns als partei und permanent auch in die
rechte ecke zu stellen und zu
deformieren und das spürt der weder das
spürt der bürger sehr genau und sollte
die cdu vor einigen jahren sagt mit dem
kurs weiterfahren uns in die ecke zu
stellen und wirklich über ein viertel
der wähler zu ignorieren und nicht
einzubinden dann wäre das ein schwerer
fehler und die cdu wird bei den nächsten
landtagswahlen noch katastrophale
abschneiden als es ohnehin schon getan
hat
man könnte es ja auch anders sehen die
ard müsste sich klarer und eindeutiger
vom rechten rand abgrenzen dann würden
sie auch aus ihrer schmuddelecke raus
kommen was meinen sie denn mit rechten
rand das verstehe ich zum beispiel
überhaupt nicht ich meine zum beispiel
die auftritte in chemnitz gemeinsam mit
rechtsradikalen die ich meine zum
beispiel die auftritte
bei p&g da ich meine zum beispiel die
äußerungen von vielen ihrer mitglieder
und funktionären und das meinen sie das
verstehen seien rechtsradikal
ich habe jetzt gerade nach ein beispiel
genannt nach einem konkreten was sie mir
nicht nennen konnten päda als
rechtsradikal zu bezeichnen
wo tausende von normalen bürger an denen
es wirklich hier steht auf die straße
gehen und für ihre stimme zu
protestieren
das würde ich nicht als rechtsradikal
mitarbeit bei p&g da demonstrationen
haben ausgewiesene rechtsradikale redner
reden gehalten
dasselbe war in chemnitz bei den
demonstrationen deswegen falls es nützt
ja nichts diese debatten immer wieder zu
führen die frage ist wollte sie klar
dann stehe ich die freiheit zu ende dann
sind sie dran wäre es nicht sinnvoll die
afg würde sich klarer abgrenzen und dann
würden sie auch mehr akzeptiert von den
anderen
die sache ist ja folgende sie haben
diese frage jetzt zweimal gestellt sie
haben mich dreimal unterbrochen ich habe
ihnen darauf geantwortet was die stunde
geschlagen hat ist es eine reine
diffamierungskampagne gegen die afg wir
werden permanent in die rechte ecke
gestellt und das neben ihnen die bürger
auch irgendwann nicht mehr ab und sie
haben heute abend bewiesen dass die
medien ein hauptteil dazu beitragen und
deshalb haben auch die bürger den
glauben in sie verloren ich wünsche
ihnen schöne abend wir versuchen unseren
jobs und herzlich